there are plenty of people who don't
want to promote they're happy doing
their job and if you give them a cost of
living adjustment every year they're
happy to sit at a certain rank for the
rest of their entire career because they
like they like that but we force people
to promote not everybody wants to be a
leader and like I know in the Air Force
I don't know if it's the same in the
Navy they keep complaining that they're
losing Pilots well stop taking them out
of the pilot seat some of them just want
to fly until their bodies won't let them
leave them nobody says they have to
command and I think again this is
reimagining the business model and I
think the best people to ask about the
business model are the people who are
subjected to it and ask them to reinvent
it and I bet you can find small groups
who are willing to volunteer to test out
new concepts of the business model you
know new ways to promote new ways to
manage a career and it may or may not
work you know it may upset a couple
careers because you're doing an
experiment but there's plenty of
entrepreneurial-minded sailors who be
like I'll do that I'm in that sounds
cool